Taylor Swift drops new single but is she
headed to halftime Plus how Beyonce ring
in her 36th birthday
hello friends they say you can't wear
white after Labor Day but today we're
making it an exception for Beyonce who
celebrated her birthday over the weekend
more on that in just a few but first it
was also a big weekend for Taylor Swift
look what you made me do just dethroned
esposito 16 weeks at number one but she
also surprised Swifty's with a new song
in case you missed it here is her latest
single ready for it
[Music]
oh we are so ready for that one the song
debuted during the Alabama versus
Florida State game on Saturday and this
is all as a source tells et Taylor will
perform at the college football national
championship in Atlanta this January our
source tells us ESPN booked her for the
event and that she has a massive deal to
drop new music from reputation during
college football season ET source adds
that this was a no-brainer for Taylor
she actually can't do the Super Bowl
halftime because well it's sponsored by
Pepsi and she has that Coca Cola
endorsement deal now et did reach out to
reps for comments on this and for now
ESPN is denying the news for the most
part Taylor has kept a pretty low
profile since releasing look what you
made me do last week but we have the
pictures of Taylor as a stunning
bridesmaid the singer helped longtime
bestie Abigail Anderson with her dress
on the way to say I do in Martha's
Vineyard alright so yesterday was Labor
Day for a lot of folks out there but for
those of us in the Beehive it was a
different national holiday I'm talking
about of course the queen bee's birthday
Beyonce turned 36 and received the Akula
saw star tribute its Michelle Obama new
mom Serena Williams these mom miss Tina
and daughter Blue Ivy all channeling
Beyonce's a formation fashion and not
only did the ladies pay tribute to the
birthday girl they also helped raise
money for the victims of Hurricane
Harvey in fact beyonce is among the
slaps who will partake in the
hand-in-hand telethon benefitting
hurricane victims that will air live on
September 12 but back to B's birthday
she rang in the special day with friends
and family at the made in America
festival in Philadelphia over the
weekend and check this out that is her
epic custom birthday cake it was
delivered right to the venue and the
shop shirt it all on Instagram cake by
the pound later that night her hubby
jay-z who headlined the festival led the
crowd in a birthday serenade for our
queen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to
[Applause]
maybe we'll change map we can save
[Music]
the birthday to you happy birthday to
you guys no I worship Beyonce and all I
gotta say is B I love you like XO and
all so when can I meet you so you can
sign my Barbie DC come on I'm ready for
it
but moving right along Beyonce's other
pal Lady gaga
did not get in on the formation fund
Mother Monster is in the middle of her
Johanne World Tour but had to cancel a
show in Canada recently due to illness
she told fans on Twitter she was
devastated she can't perform but as a
consolation for the little monsters
waiting outside her hotel she ordered
them pizza and how fitting because today
just so happens to be national cheese
pizza day folks let me tell you pizza
makes everything better doesn't it all
right before we get out of here e t--'s
Kevin Frazier recently caught up with
Kevin Hart at his annual heartbeat
fundraiser in Las Vegas Hart and his
wife and Nico are expecting their first
child together she's seven months
pregnant and feeling fine now but we
uncovered Hart's baby plan let's just
say diapers are not part of that plan
are you ready for diaper duty no I
thought you would come around doing
nothing I told you man so what are you
I mean doesn't work here I mean a cane
yeah man talk to him it's a good boy i
got a boy coming over I would talk to
him every once a while I'll yell what up
good but he has also an older brother
who will help I got nothing
my daughter 12 my son Don about to be
dead my wife is right something tells me
that's totally gonna change once that
baby boy arrives Kevin are you guys
that's it for us today so be sure to hit
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel so
you don't miss another episode of daily
Denny I've got a lot cooking up for you
this week and of course stick with ET
online.com for all the latest and
entertainment news by Beyonce we love
you in the darling